first time i played thor i was like
shirt off no worries we're talking 11
years of transformations not only for
chris hemsworth but for every character
throughout the entire thor franchise
we'll be discussing natalie portman's
insane workout routine tessa thompson's
mealtime secrets and christian bales
five hour long makeup process
number one
natalie portman is definitely no
stranger to intense transformations
she's done training regimens over 40
hours a week in preparation for black
swan so of course thor love and thunder
would be no different to become mighty
thor the only thing requested of her was
to get as big as possible and eat as
much as possible there are a lot of
protein shakes um like too many and i
don't want to have it
natalie found herself getting a little
annoyed at one particular vegetable that
kept getting served at every meal it was
like breakfast lunch and dinner would
have asparagus in that the only thing
that's available right now fun fact that
was a request from her co-star tessa
thompson because asparagus really helped
the muscles pop i was like hot tip tessa
so like now i won't complain about that
number two
speaking of tessa she definitely didn't
get off easy when it came to
transforming into her character valkyrie
right before heading off to australia to
film thor she was finishing up her role
as josie in the film annihilation
i had to start training for thor while
we were making annihilation one of the
big areas of training was all the swords
work not only did she have to master her
sword but she was also trained by
reginald brantley who is actually known
for training bodybuilding competitors
we're talking an intense amount of
cardio and weightlifting it seems like
this would be pretty grueling work for
anyone but tessa actually loved it
especially after coming out of a period
of being on the couch a lot to just feel
better in my body frankly number three
chris hemsworth has been training for
thor for over a decade now
so bulking up has become pretty natural
for him on his own he loves working out
it's actually become a bit of an
addiction for him but he describes
bulking up to thor size as pretty brutal
on his body
in an interview with center one of
chris's trainers speaks up about his
routine noting that the actor had to
consume a massive 4 500 calories a day
in order to fuel his gun-tastic
transformation
that's up to six meals a day
even chris's stunt double bobby holland
had to gain over 20 pounds of lean
muscle in under 10 weeks to convincingly
play thor's double
number 4 christian bale's career has
seen a plethora of insane
transformations
his process for turning into gore the
god butcher has less to do with him
bulking up or eating veggies but more so
the incredibly talented makeup team
behind the look he spends four hours in
the makeup chair at the beginning of the
day and over an hour and a half at the
end ain't just me it's
adam and it's emily and it's color as
well who bust their ass creating this
look number five
taika waititi had a similar experience
turning into korg being taken seriously
as a director when you're wearing
fractal pajamas is
not easy but of course being the
director adds a bit of comedic element
to it and you've got these dots all over
your face and stuff and you know it's
the most
um emasculating experience though tyka
is used to acting in his own films he
purposely made his scenes in the thor
franchise as simple as possible so he
could just enjoy playing the role
without a ton of pressure on his
shoulders
number six
legendary russell crowe has been
hilariously known for doing little to no
prep for his roles
i did no preparation whatsoever
i researched absolutely nothing but for
thor love and thunder he did have to do
a bit of accent work taika ytt spoke
with insider about russell crowe's
journey of transforming into zeus we
actually talked at length about the
accent we wondered if someone did a
greek accent of a greek god is it going
to be a farce will it be too silly
russell was very much wanting it to be
greek but i wasn't sure so we ended up
doing two versions of every take with
russell one in a greek accent and then
another in a british accent
number seven
also known as the incredible hulk
now mark's transformation is quite a bit
different than the other actors mostly
because his character is completely
animated and they put black dots
in specific places all over my face he
also has a camera attached to his head
that records all of his facial
expressions so my makeup process really
is where they record me doing a bunch of
different motions in the first two thor
movies mark had to do every single one
of his scenes by himself weeks before
the actors even stepped foot on set but
in ragnarok the technology advanced in a
way where he didn't have to do that
anymore and that makes a world of
difference you know we could do improv
we can improvise whole scenes together
now and they could capture all that
number eight this wasn't your average
transformation
what
jeff goldblum's transition into the
grand master for thor ragnarok is not
exactly the protein shake road like his
co-star natalie portman but more of a
makeup experimentation we camera tested
something that they'd sewn up
they said
let's do something else not only was
jeff part of the initial conversation
about his character's look but he also
got to vote on things he liked or
disliked we changed that costume and
then they had masterful hair people i
think they did my hair in eight
different ways he was super flexible
about the whole process and didn't
complain once
let's give it a try i love this this is
my favorite part on camera number nine
did you know tom hiddleston originally
auditioned for thor though everyone
thought he would be better suited for
loki it didn't spare him the hours of
intense training the rest of the cast is
pretty familiar with so he said chris
and tom go and train together there's
some tree trunks um in the garden for
firewood that unique training regimen
involved lifting tree trunks together
needless to say chris hemsworth and tom
hiddleston became fast friends
number 10
we obviously can't talk about loki
without bringing up matt damon now if
your kids are looking at you right now
like that's not tom hiddleston just tell
him i was loki in the 90s before it was
cool loki has had quite the
transformation throughout the mcu matt
damon spoke on the jess cage show about
taika waititi's comic decision of
bringing in matt damon we were kind of
reprising a cameo that luke hemsworth
and i did in the last one
apparently taika asked luke and matt to
kind of run that joke back and upgrade
it a little bit and that they did number
11
like christian bale we've got another
master of transformations here
not only does she get to wear these
super stylish as taika waititi put it
freckle pajamas for all the cgi shots
but she also got her own practical hella
helmet i think we nailed it it looks
when i first shot on her her walking
around the studio it was pretty
impressive
caitlyn chet was also pretty heavily
involved in hela's regular day-to-day
look
and i was saying well she can't wear
that all the time what's it like when
she doesn't have it on they let us have
a bit of free reign with that number 12.
now this was worth waiting for marvel
fans had been dying to see scourge the
executioner face off against thor long
before ragnarok came out so when carl
urban teased a little bit about his new
look for the film it was definitely a
big deal he even shared a picture on
twitter thanking taiwaititi for his new
clean-shaven look
we've got hours of time in the makeup
chair incredible practical and visual
effects and an insane amount of protein
shakes who do you think had the most
intense transformation in the thor
franchise